our series of more perfect union aims
and i would say succeeds in showing us
that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us in
the city of brotherly love you don't
have to visit an art museum to see
beautiful paintings there's an
innovative program in philadelphia
using art to transform public spaces and
as
our arrow barnett shows it's also
changing lives
right here was where you would sleep
each night right here for five years
michael bello often used this bench in
philadelphia's suburban station as his
bed
so how does it feel now to walk through
here
on your way to your job it feels it
feels amazing you know
sometimes that's why i gotta i gotta
remind myself you know just come sit
right there you know
just to be grateful be thankful that
you're in a situation you're with now
bellows job is steps away in this cafe
turned workshop
it's home to color me back an initiative
of mural arts philadelphia
helping bellow and others face and
overcome life's hardships
one brush stroke at a time there's a lot
of people that come to this program you
know
you know they look at me like you know
bellow you know he was homeless you know
he got herself together they see me they
like you know he you know bello you know
he can do he's a role model that makes a
lot of people you know
when they want to change their life
around those experiencing economic and
housing insecurity are offered the
chance to create murals and public art
earning 50 for each morning's work
connecting people in need with useful
social services
and beautifying philly along the way art
is a lifeline
that it opens other doors jane golden
grew mural
philadelphia into what is now the
nation's largest
public art organization how did the
program get its name
it was in our early classes and the
participants came up with the idea that
it would be called color me back
it's because people really feel that
they're brought back to life through the
art
we're gonna crack open the sealer okay
right now arlene williams is
experiencing her own revival
thanks to bellows outreach i stayed in
the parkway
when they had the encampments in the
parkway what did bello say to you
um every day he came and it was like i
just want to encourage someone
to get off the street and i guess i was
the best candidate
so he was saying it to everybody yes but
it really resonated with you
why is that because this just being on
the street wasn't the place
for me i wanted better for myself
and having places like this it was a
stepping stone they gave me so many
chances here
it's just a place of love and a place of
being and
what else have you gotten out of this
access um
i've sustained housing for seven months
now i completed school
so it's this is this is this is
everything that i needed
so far the program's paid out more than
150
000 to nearly 650 participants
because we're surrounded by the names of
all the people who've come through this
program
and have been impacted by it what is
this moment like for you to see
those names you know it's very humbling
actually
we have a scarcity model in our society
we think well we can't afford it we
can't do that that's never going to
happen
but suddenly when you make an investment
in the human spirit and in human
potential
this is what we see this kind of
potential and that it leads to other
things
and that is how the world changes
proving that sometimes the most
transformative art
is a blank canvas for cbs this morning
errol barnett philadelphia it seems like
such a basic idea to now have
all those names on the wall of people
they've helped it's incredible i like
what she says art is a lifeline and it
opens other doors yeah true basic idea
of a beautiful one
really so